you
you
Thank You counselor gold
it was very nice fair welcome to this
meeting of the council my first remind
you all of some of the domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water which you might all
need today is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet only its which
Town Football Club cleaning pitch do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it's safe to do so please switch off all
mobile phones or turn them to silent I
would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt aired
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you'll be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this room
you're also consenting to being filmed
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and all for training purposes
the council members of the public in the
press may recalled film photographs or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally can members and officers please
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn off when finished
right I'm going to move on to the agenda
now please members I'm moving item ten
capital investment fund company Cisco
Capital Limited business training and
performance report 2018-19
part one to further on in the agenda to
be taken before
or item 13 all other items will remain
in the same order so we'll now move on
to the main body of the meeting item 1
apologies for absence Thank You chair we
have received apologies from councillor
Mabry thank you
declaration of interest by councillors
cancer halt
yes chair I declare personal interest in
labor side of holdings and SIF go as I'm
a director upon any other declarations
of interest by councillors ok yes Clara
interest obviously in paper holdings
which was item 10 Thank You councillor
Busby item 3 BC oh I'm sorry just to
also include myself in that declaration
personal declaration of interest is a
director of their companies Thank You
councillor Hinton any further
declarations of interest by councillors
thank you moves on to item 3 then BC
1910 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 25th June for accuracy
only Thank You councillor gold for fear
of being labeled a parent but those who
have worked with me before know that I
am actually a touch pedantic I think the
minutes it's a typo I'm sure but on page
six item 822 I think probably we would
like to read councillor beer agreed with
councillor McCraw and second to the
proposal have extended the consultation
period to ten weeks and on page seven
item nine three I suspect we would like
it to read councillor Ward stated that
the housing delivery action plan
justified the joint with a tea on the
end thank you
Thank You counselor gold I think those
are sensible changes anything else that
any would like to have altered if before
we say it's an accurate set of minutes
right thank you so can we have a vote
for or against the minutes for the
minutes please oh sorry
can I have a proposal for the minutes
please confirm the minutes counts a
bitter thank you can I have a seconder
please House respond thank you all those
for the minutes please that's carried
thank you item 4 BC 1911 announcements
from the Chairman and leader I refer you
to paper BC 1911 for noting please also
note that the start time of the next
meeting on 24 September has been moved
to 6 p.m. as there's a chance that the
county meeting on the same day could run
over Thank You counsel ward do you have
anything to report yes thank you
chairman as I mentioned last month I
went on a two days a DCN study torterue
Solara
and belgium at the end of june Russa
Lara has implemented many of the
recommendations in the 2013 grimsy
review an alternative future for the
high street and we learned how they went
about this what have achieved and so far
and the lessons that they have learned
just to quickly run through some of the
main achievements they've changed their
library into a knowledge center which
includes pop-up space for micro
businesses therefore converted City
Center parking into main square in the
main squares to green space with
children's play areas and they've also
revitalized side streets and alleyways
they've worked with landlords to bring
empty units back into use and other
empty units they've been you
been used to enable startups to rent
space on a popup basis with low rent and
tax for a year and then assistance that
the venture is going to be a long-term
success other retail successes have been
the introduction of mixed mode stores
combining retail and and other
experience based activities also
providing at different uses in the
daytime and evenings and also an
increase in town center residential
accommodation
they've restricted development of
out-of-town retail they've implemented a
new charging policy for parking
including free thirteen minutes in the
city center they've got free Wi-Fi a
city app showing available parking
discounts and other information and a
single brand for the town in the past
two years about 30 to 40 new shops have
opened some have been short term pop-ups
but many are permanent lettings there
has been a significant reduction in
vacancy rates they have experienced a
real quantifiable increase in town
centre business and although it is a
bigger town many of the things that they
have done would also work on Sudbury and
for that matter Stowe market - and it
has given us a lot of ideas for real
projects of our own keeping on the high
streets theme along with the other
leaders in the county I am disappointed
that nowhere in Suffolk received a
future high street funding in the first
round of bidding some of the towns that
were successful as surprising in the
least however I remain committed to our
high streets I want to see some projects
underway in Sudbury in particular soon
I'm pleased that the vision for
prosperity work that I Headley and need
a market has been well received by the
public it's great news at the
consultation period for the joint local
plan preferred options was launched
yesterday and will close at 4:00 p.m. on
Monday 30th of September
please encourage all of your town and
parish councils and residents to get
involved and have their say on the
proposals I'm also very pleased at the
recent announcement that both beta and
mid Suffolk have regained their
five-year housing land supplies in the
recent annual position statements this
is only a draft position while a
four-week consultation is undertaken
however the provisional number of 578
years including a 5% buffer is
encouraging last week saw the start of
major changes to our pink elections
affecting approximately 70% of our
residents there were the inevitable TV
teething problems but that can report
that in the first week in beta I have
approximately 40,000 collections last
week we only have 77 outstanding miss
bins there was a particular problem
Shotley which was a result of an
overzealous refuse collector coming for
bins two days early but this was
completely resolved by the end of the
week can we all reiterate the message to
our residents that this will take a week
or two it'll settle down and to report
any issues in the normal way so that
they can be resolved I'm sure you'll all
have seen the recent communication about
free swimming for children at our
leisure centers throughout the six-week
summer holiday this is an excellent
example of how we can can and do get
things done quickly this was done in
less than four weeks from the initial
suggestion by the cabinet member for
communities through discussions with a
betrothed
pleasure to the formal announcement two
weeks ago now I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank councillor Davis
Johnson Severson Cassandra Clements a
Beecroft 11 pleasure and others for
working so quickly to implement this so
please communicate this to all your
towns and parishes so that all of our
children know about it and can take
advantage of it over the summer
particularly this week but if the
weather so hot and finally I've been
asked to make a brief mention for two
other community initiatives there's a
recently announced Active Schools
program that involves 20 schools in
Weber and mid Suffolk and finally the
announcement out today about the silk
storage project in Sudbury Thank You
chairman Thank You council board so we
move on now to item 5 to receive
nificant notification of petitions in
accordance with council procedural rules
Thank You chair
no no petitions were received thank you
thank you
item 6 questions by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
the deputy monitoring officer has
referred question 1 to council award as
who was the portfolio holder at the time
the report was taken to cabinet as
you've seen you've got some question
we've got two questions by a member of
the public
mr. register is not here so I shall read
out the question question one council
award from mr. register on behalf of
bellevue rescue restore and revives
steering group in accordance with local
authorities executive arrangements
meetings and access to information
england regulations 2012 a key decision
needs to be included in the forthcoming
decisions list with at least 28 clear
days notice the current list does not
include any key decision to consider
funds associated with planning on the
potential bellevue proposal why is this
key decision missing from the
forthcoming decisions list council ward
would you please respond
Thank You chairman Jeff just to clarify
I'm asking this because council of buzz
people wasn't a cabinet member at the
time but I was I was lead at the time at
its meeting on 11th of October 2018
cabinet approved earmarking of funds
from Babers portion of the 2018 to 19
suffolk business rates retention pilot
to support a number of proposed
regeneration schemes in the district
five hundred thousand powers was him up
to Bellevue Hamilton Road and the wider
Sudbury Town Center development some of
this money will be used to support the
planning application for our proposed
hotel and restaurant at Bellevue this
cabinet item first appeared on the
forthcoming decisions list on 30th of
August 2018 reference CA B 82 thank you
thank you
there was a second question so likewise
I'll read out question to councillor
Ward from mr. register on behalf of
Bellevue Rescue restore and revised
steering group and question is as
follows please can you confirm that the
cost for the Bellevue proposal have been
assessed under the key decisions
requirements
as per part one twelve point seven point
one in the Constitution and what was the
result of the assessment council award
please respond I'm reading the
Constitution I think that should be
corrected to 1291 because the
Constitution was revised and that's the
section on key decisions that's been
noted thank you Constitution has it as
12.94 while unfortunately their
forthcoming decisions of this document
needs to be updated to bring it in line
with Constitution that will that will
happen however it's a substantive answer
now I can confirm that the costs for our
proposed hotel and restaurant were
assessed under the key decisions for
Congress as per part one twelve point
nine point one of the Constitution and
this assessment was part of the evidence
debated and proved by Cabinet in the
12th of July 2018
this was item 16 on the published agenda
for that meeting and was discussed in
confidential session this cabinet item
first appeared on the forthcoming
decisions list on the 3rd of April 2018
reference CA B 36 it was then debated
and approved by counsel at the meeting
held on the 25th of September 2018
this was item 15 on the published agenda
for that meeting and again was discussed
in confidential session the minutes
remain confidential and so I cannot
provide full details of the assessment
but I can confirm that based on the
assessment a council approved the
development and its capital funding and
B the anticipated revenue effects over
the initial 25-year lease will provide a
net income to the council every year
from year 2 onwards Thank You chairman
Thank You councillor Ward well now move
on to quite item 7 item 7 questions by
councillors in accordance with council
procedure Awards
thank you there were none received thank
you thank you
so we'll now move on to 8 BC 1912
overview in scrutiny committee report
I'd like to invite councilman
to introduce his report which is for
noting Thank You chair I've been
instructed to keep this short and you'll
note there's only two pages for once and
fundamentally the two meetings that
paper refers to in BC 1912 the first of
those on the 24th of June just dealt
with the initial meeting for the Baber
committee we discussed an update on the
CFP s scrutiny symposium the government
have relaunched their statutory guidance
on overview and scrutiny and local
authorities we examined this is only
released that day and I'm pleased to
report that officers and myself and my
colleague at Suffolk found that our
current practice was actually completely
in line with the most up-to-date recent
government's thinking they also
published an updated version on the same
day of the good scrutiny guide that's
worth attention for anybody and it's
available as a download from the CFP s
on their website or from offices for
members of the council we also looked at
our work plan in our timetable that is a
developing process based upon previous
years agreements of what work would be
carried forward the meeting held on the
first of July dealt with the capital
investment fund company as its major
item the basis since that forms one of
the reports in today's paper we have
requested in our recommendations that
our minutes be added to this report so
you have those minutes before you it's
really just the idea that we asked
extensive questions you may wish to
follow up on those but it might help
avoid a certain amount of repetition
that we do get in process of looking at
Cisco I'm happy to take questions on the
paper but obviously anything relating to
the Cisco would probably be best kept
for that part of the agenda thank you
Thank You counsel macaw has anyone got
any questions that they'd like to ask
outs
McCraw no right we'll move on to item 9
Thank You councillor McCraw item 9 bc
1913 equality and diversity policy I'd
like to invite councillor Ward to
introduce the paper and to move the
recommendation in the report thank you
Thank You chairman members I present to
you an equality and diversity policy
which demonstrates the council's
commitment to embedding the Equality Act
2010 which includes the public sector
equality Duty for the right of
individuals to be treated equally and
fairly the Equality Act 2010 brought
together over 116 separate pieces of
legislation into one single act
providing a legal framework to protect
the rights of individuals in advancing
equality of opportunity for all since
the introduction of the Act there have
been many changes to the legislation and
factual and supported guidance has been
provided to public authorities it's
therefore timely to bring in a policy to
support and provide guidance including
duties and responsibilities and respect
to the nine protected characteristics
and to cement the way in which we are
carrying out our duties in line with the
acts as a council we have agreed that
using equality impact assessments is the
most effective way to demonstrate that
we have paid due regard these are
completed alongside a screening process
are our major decisions and identify
that impacts of any proposed changes
have been considered according to the
proposed to the protected
characteristics our communities are
becoming more diverse and we support and
foster good relations between protected
groups it is important that our policies
and service delivery reflect both these
diverse and sometimes similar needs this
also includes our workforce and our
commitment to ensuring all officers feel
included and play their part in making
the castle great places to live work and
visit this equality and diversity policy
is an overarching document that embeds
best practice of equality and diversity
and is supported by guidance and
resource this topic will continue to
evolve
and counsel are asked to recommend the
cabinet the approval of this policy to
demonstrate our commitment to support
and promote the diversity of our
communities in accordance with the Act I
therefore propose the recommendation in
paragraph 3 of the report the full
council discusses the equality and
diversity policy provided at Appendix A
and recommends to cabinet that it be
adopted Thank You chairman Thank You
counsel
we have a seconder please Thank You
counselor right this is now open for
questions and debate
Thank You page 19 1.2 we list a whole
list of characteristics that should be
the one thing we miss these politics I
think that's a valid point because I do
know that in some areas of our economy
people feel intimidated to express their
political views an interesting addition
and certainly we do not discriminate to
discriminate against politics of any
sort in this chamber we are a diverse
chamber and we enjoy healthy debate we
could probably consider adding that but
interesting our chief executives would
like to comment if I can perhaps
assistant and trying to avoid a comedy
moment you will undoubtedly be aware
that unfortunately for yourselves as
politicians you are not a protected
characteristic within the law
I'm sure government might wish to
consider making politicians a protected
characteristic but at the moment you're
not and that's why politics politics is
not listed albeit a point that you were
looking beyond simply politicians in
that regard because there's something to
consider councilor Hinton thank you
about chairmen yes I just find it a
little bit strange that we're talking
about equality and diversity and yet
we're talking about certain
characteristics protected
characteristics and those who aren't in
a protected characteristic presume he
can be discriminated against and
generally abused as much as it's
necessary
surely the very nature of being
something that see
equal means that everybody is included
and not just certain groups consumer
cruel I'd refer Catholic in Shinto one
point three we will not treat anyone
less favorably than any other I think
that answers this point
Kevin if I can come back and just say
that the the further apart of that step
that sentence does say on the grounds of
any protected characteristic so it's
discriminating against different
characteristics straightaway
hair-splitting to be done because the
BuzzFeed there is a point if you make a
list of items that you've got to be
protected on then every venture allottee
surely the point of 1.3 that we would
not treat anyone less favor than any
other is sufficient that should cover
every every every eventualities
cuts award yeah I think we can argue
forever over whether they should be
listed or what should be in the list but
the one quick point I do wish to to add
is that since the agenda pack was
published that list has been expanded
with more detail of definitions of what
each of those characteristics are as a
result of a request and feedback from
counselor Mabry and I don't know
presumably we'll be able to get that
updated list provided to members but we
got it we've got a list and we have to
live with it
so it appears that that list is going to
be passed to us with an expanded detail
are we ready now to go to the vote in
this is anyone oh sorry
our chief executives once Thank You
chairman you'll have notice members that
the report is there for your
consideration and then passed forward to
cabinet given that the sense of the of
the room what I would suggest is that
it's passed forward to cabinet and that
cabinet explores whether it's possible
to broaden beyond those just those
protected characteristics before cabinet
and Dobson policy but I've been
refraining from saying anything kurz but
I hate to turn people to think the mood
of the room is all against this the
reasons there are protected
characteristics for some people it's
because they regarded as more vulnerable
than other people and if we don't accept
that we don't accept that some people
are more vulnerable than others then
then you know there's no point having
this whole cants agreeing to helmet to
to echo your point I think those
characteristics are really important
because the obviously general feel of
this room deco Arthur's common is that
perhaps we don't understand those
characteristics that it's all the more
important is that those lists are there
for people that don't understand the
varying people that we are nowadays so
I'd like the list as it is personal or
that's just again the point of that list
is that these are groups that have in
the past previously been discriminated
against that's the whole point of the
legislation we have to report code to
the legislation so I'm arguing for
groups that we have not yet identified
as having been a discriminated against
we may be moving faster than we need to
for the moment this is a list that
described the worst of what happened in
the past okay we want to avoid those
mistakes
I can't separate thank you I just wanted
to say we we are perhaps entering to it
slightly unnecessary debate because we
are following the Equality Act and if it
stipulated in the Equality Act then that
is what we must do and I don't really
think we need to go beyond the Equality
Act because I think the groups that we
need to be concerned about are covered
adequately by this this this policy that
we're we're about to prove so I'm happy
with as it stands any more comments or
any more questions councillor Ward is
there anything else you wanted to add
thank you so I think if we're ready I
think we can go to the vote all those in
favor that's carried unanimously thank
you
Thank You chairman there was some
confusion when the the list of
appointing pointees to external bodies
was published a while ago I just want to
clarify that for the Western Suffolk
Community Safety Partnership there are
two members appointed counsel McClaren
and councillor Davis thank you um I do
need a seconder for this please thank
you can't so Neumann all those in favor
thank you that scariet item tat 12
missions on natus I would like to fight
counts involve a Z to move the motion
thank you madam chairman I'd like to
brief counsel on some background
information before I laid motion before
the United Nations Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change warned warned
that we have 12 years to make the
necessary changes to limits a rise in
global temperatures to 1.5 centigrade
failure to act will see a marked
increase in sea levels and flooding
extreme and abrupt changes to weather
patterns which were experiencing crop
failures extinctions of plant insect
animal species and global economic
disruption crisis total populations of
mammals birds fish and reptiles have
declined globally by 60 percent since
1970 and all of the twenty warmest years
on record have occurred in the past 22
years failure to take immediate action
and decisive action on this will
detrimental impact on the well-being of
the people of baver district and
billions of people around the world
because no man is an island at the
global climate talks in Poland last
December the UK along with over 200
nations agreed action on climate change
with a much greater role strongly
implied for local and regional
authorities in assisting governments to
achieve their carbon emission savings so
far 85 local and regional authorities
have past climate emergency motions in a
bid to spur urgent action to reduce
their carbon footprint and to promote
sustainable urban environments and
economies in passing and following
through on this motion we can take a
step forward in tackling climate change
and conversation
conservation as a local authority
tackling climate change cannot just be
left to national government it is
everyone's duty to do what they can to
stop this existential threat to our
planet now the action that I would like
to see as the portfolio hold are moving
forward is that this council therefore
resolves to support the environmental
sustainability task force to consider
the following actions commission an
environmental audit which identifies
pollution hotspots wildlife biodiversity
and environmental health issues an urban
impact assessment with an aim to with an
aim to identify areas of improvement
across the district consult expert
opinions in the field as appropriate
collaborate with regional and
neighboring local authorities as well as
communities to encourage practical
measures to reduce emissions reduce
carbon footprints and develop
community-based renewable energy
projects encourage all sectors of the
economy across the borough to take steps
to reduce waste and become carbon
neutral develop a roadmap for Baber
District Council to go carbon neutral by
2030
report to cabinet and full council
within six months of the taskforce
starting with an action plan setting out
conservation and environmental
sustainability goals to address the
targets by 2030 incorporating proposals
on the investment implications of this
proposed activity write to the Minister
of State for energy and clean growth
requesting that national policy is
urgently developed to reflect the
seriousness of the current emergency and
to release funds to authorities
encouraging them to take the necessary
measures
local levels so the motion I put forward
before council is one acknowledged a
climate change a climate emergency to
set up a task force commencing by
September 2019 to examine ways in which
Weber and mid Suffolk Council's will
respond to the climate change challenge
on a spend to save basis with the
ambition to make Baber and myth Suffolk
councils carbon neutral by 2030 to work
with partners across the county and
region including local enterprise
partnership public sector leaders
towards the aspiration of making the
county of Suffolk carbon neutral by 2030
to work with government to a deliver its
25-year environment plan and be
increased the powers and resources
available to local authorities in order
to make the target of 2030 easier to
achieve thank you madam chairman Thank
You councilman Quincy now have a
seconder please councillor Ward thank
you so now we can move to questions and
debates cuts of Hardacre I'd like to
propose an amendment everyone's got the
briefing paper that was handed out for
Scott the wording highlight first of all
I'd say we I welcome this motion I would
put winning myself how do you not
believe and we're going for it in any
case and the purpose of this amendment
is not to mr. hopefully work in a
collaborative manner to try and so as
well notice that I'm good to insert
suggest we insert a second point which
is to a standalone point in the motion
to declare a call to make the carbon
count the cabin the council carbon
neutral by 2030 in the existing second
point you mentioned as ambition it does
say target later on but I think having
is a clear bullet point is a more of a
statement of intent
up front that we could that we could try
and meet i also furs so i am to becomes
I am free and I've completely reworded
this to to read requesting 2019 a
cabinet member for the environment that
convenes a working group of citizens
selected to revoke reflect the change
range of demographics in the district
this group would meet to consider the
climate change impacts of each area of
the council's activities and in
consultation with scientific and expert
advisors produced a set of
recommendations for ways to bring each
of these areas to zero by 2030 task
force working group you can call it
anything you want the key here is to get
members of the public involved from the
get-go
rather than the usual suspects so we say
in that was in this room in this
building meeting and then putting
recommendations to people at some kind
of consultation we get them involved
from the start and there is questions
for this in Camden they've recently done
this exercise they met for three days
they got 50 local people they've got
some experts and they produce the
recommendations this weekend just come
Boxford are doing a similar process and
I say this em bleed I've called it with
fifty people again and they are meeting
in September for two weekends so there's
precedent for this there's more urban
councils with my rural but you know
maybe we could be the first more rural
council to do that I am free I've
slightly reworded to include the sort of
climate change partnership in that list
and also that we should implement the
recommendations of the working group so
not a great deal of change it's a little
bit more beefing up making it more clear
on our goal is to in group include the
public from the get-go and you know
bring those recommendations
Thank You counselor Hardaker can we have
a seconder please thank you did you want
to speak just like the echo Rick's words
incensed by certain recommendations and
goals rather than aspirations and
ambitions we're sort of setting
ourselves targets too we can actually
meet and rather than leaving some of
these things a bit loose Thank You
councillor Jameson cuts them lvz do you
accept this amendment madam chairman no
I don't and I don't for the following
reasons we have set up we are going to
set up a task force we say in our motion
that we are working with our local our
partners and the Suffolk climate change
partnership is in fact one of our
partners already so it's sort of it's
just producing a longer list whereas I
prefer to be more direct and
to-the-point and get the job done a
citizen's panel we were elected to be
that panel we have been elected to be
the voice of the people that they should
be included at some stage absolutely but
I don't think that it's at this stage in
the motion that they should be included
this is a motion to basically commit the
council to recognising climate change
and doing something about it I've said
in the action points that we will come
back to Council within six months with
our plan how it's going to actually
succeed and I think that it's at that
point that we involved people because
it's at that point we will have set out
the terms and terms of reference for the
task force which is critical to its
success
because if we don't have terms of
reference to a task force it just
becomes a nebulous nonentity so it's
critical that we get those terms of
reference finalized and they will come
back to Council for approval I think yes
our colleague councillor McGraw will go
through them with a fine-tooth comb so
on that basis I think that there is no
need for your amendment at this stage
thank you very much
Thank You councilman feizi
Oh right so we're going to open to
questions and debate on the amendment
councillor Ward Thank You chairman yeah
I'd like to reiterate what councilor VC
has said and we use words such as
ambition and aspiration simply because
we all know that the 2013 date is going
to be very very difficult to achieve the
government has set a 2050 date but we
are setting ourselves a challenge and
therefore we need to rise to that
challenge but it has to be an ambition
and a very bold one but more importantly
a citizen's panel they tend to be
stuffed with activists and zealots and
and not end up representative [ __ ] as
customer VC has stated we are the
elected representatives we live in a
representative democracy and indeed we
have a very fresh mandate we were only
elected a few weeks ago therefore it is
beholden upon us as the counselors here
to form a task group and to do this work
ourselves on behalf of our our electors
and also of course has canceled my visa
said we all consult where where
appropriate where necessary but it is
our responsibility to not do this we'll
be shirking that responsibility cancer
Lindsay Thank You chair just to correct
the impression it councillor Ward says
it will be a citizen's panel as you've
called it we've not called it a
citizen's panel we just said
a group of citizens selected to reflect
the range of demographics in the
district so we're not asking it's not
know me self-selecting they're not
saying all we activists come forward
whoever wants to the way this works in
the cases that are excited it's almost
like a jury system you look at the
electoral registry and you select people
based on and I'm actually you you pay
them for coming so they're not it's not
self selecting eaten by the ones that
can afford to come to give up a weekend
or can you provide a small token so that
they can afford to come and that's the
exciting thing about this way of doing
things is that you are genuinely
involving a proper cross-section of our
citizens in in babe not just so there
might be people on there who think that
climate change is a load of rubbish you
know equally there with people with you
know degrees in climate change possibly
but everyone's gets a chance to think of
ideas because a task force of a few
councillors yes we've all been elected
but it will just be a select
self-selected group of counselors on
this task force won't be able to to come
up with everything there's so much that
needs to be done it's a sea change in
policies we're talking about but I think
we need that added input now I hear what
you're saying that you can it's not
you're not ruling ruling out that idea
hopefully because I hope that if we if
this amendment Falls that we could still
look to do that as part of some how to
report back to a task force or some
other way but I really hope it does this
idea even if this amendment rules does
get taken on board Thank You councillor
Dawson councillor Dawson yes
one of the things I would actually
comment on this is actually it's
slightly inflammatory because actually
many consider this slight needle charge
and associated with sometimes extremism
when we look at nationally the mechanics
are in place at a national level to deal
with climate change the committee
actually does that and they set their
carbon budgets to reduce or emissions
that's already done so we're definitely
already on the pathway to
decarbonisation and one of the problems
with this which like it may concern me
it's the fact that if we go faster in
Suffolk we can actually damage the
economy or damage the lives of
hard-working people excuse me
or go to hospital so I think going
faster can actually end up with this
sporting emissions and therefore
increasing global emissions because
these are some of these against
countries where they don't actually
effectively deal with them as well as we
do here so I'll be talking to a main
motion now or the amendment cut so
Lindsey we're talking to the Amendment
yes
so the big words emergency are in the
main ocean that Council Mel VZ is
proposing yep
so you're objecting to the main motion
no no not making comment we need to
stick to the main to the amendment at
this time
yes I've actually gone on to say the
point of this is the fact that if we're
going faster this is what concerns me I
do always repeat it I think that's in
the mains but it's appropriate this is
what we can come to that in the next
stage cuts the Fraser did you want to
say anything do you had your hand up
earlier yes thank you madam chairman
just picking up on what counsel the
Lindsey was saying there correct me if I
pick this up wrong please he's saying
that we'd be selecting
members from the public from the
electoral roll and offer them rewards
who actually come along on a Saturday to
actually access our working group or
something to me to look at this climate
emergency I think that would be
unworkable because the turnout at
elections are low enough in the 30
percent but for to ask residents to give
up their weekends I think have been a
even lower turnout so I think for that
idea it would be a low take-up and very
ineffective so I think unworkable
thank you Kelso counts from accrual
thank you madam chair I'm really never
quite certain with madam chairman
chairman I know you always said you
wanted to be called chairman but just
you know so I might I might bury my
terminology at different times I'm not
totally happy I think many members have
been be entirely happy about being
described as the usual suspects
to be honest with you I think we're a
pretty unusual bunch of suspects one of
the great things I think about bayberry
has passed and particularly this present
is the range of diversity of opinion
with five separate political groups now
it's not been discussed how the task
force might be made up are some ideas on
that I'd like to see representatives
from each the political groups because
again I think the rep rep rip the
residents of Baber are going to ask
themselves a question why are you press
joining us into this even if it's only
thirty percent of us turn up when
fundamentally we elected you to do this
I mean isn't this part of your job and
I'd have to say I'm a incredible
sympathy with the green approach here
but you have a mandate to do just what
you've got elected for that's you to do
that that's what the people who are
elected and the people who voted green
across the district they expected you to
do that now green issues are now no
longer the exclusive right of one
particular political party every single
one of us has a green agenda to some
degree or other now you can vary the
amount of it how high up our agendas it
might be but the very point that this
motion has come forward on is the fact
that it's now on everybody's agenda
success for green politics is a now a
national international issue and yes
it's difficult to get other countries to
come in fundamentally we're arguing
about the terms I mean frankly whether
we have it as a target an ambition or a
goal these are all synonyms for the same
word this is what we want to do we're
going to try and do so fundamentally I
think I have to speak against the
Amendment because I'm not particularly
happy about citizens assembly didn't
work too well for Russian Revolution or
for the French Revolution and I'm not
wearing a cockade or anything like that
let's just say that the motion as it
stands is sufficient unto the purpose
however it's a starting point anyway and
it's what we do after that starting
point the other thing I'd say is that I
don't know how long it would take to
organize as a citizen's assembly but I
can't imagine it's gonna happen
overnight
that's all I'm sorry I think it comes
from a court
does anyone else want to debate the
amendment council Buzzbee
I'm just I'd like to ask them a question
this has already been done in other
areas presumably you mentioned it so it
can't be that difficult hey I'd like to
know maybe not now but I'd like to know
what the outcome of those meetings was
and how successful we were perhaps you
could just cut some heartache did you
want to make a comment on this and just
yeah briefly I mean in terms of time
the I don't know how long it took to set
up but the Oxford part was a couple of
months ago in their meeting in September
then the Camden group has already met
and done it was three days a week apart
something and they've come up with
several recommendations seventeen
recommendations if you like I don't know
precise details but it is a cost across
trouble installing solar power transport
waste is pause on things so yeah it was
well it was a rousing fast process and
yeah came out was there recommendations
which then went to the council so
thank you
cut some mouths easy thank you madam
chairman hmm if I can just answer a
couple of points that have been raised
it concerns me that somebody is using an
electoral roll to write two people to
join whether it's a task force or a
working group or a citizen's panel it
doesn't matter but I'd have to get
confirmation that under gdpr we you
could do that and I wouldn't want to
expose the council to that because as I
said previously and it's been supported
by councillor McGraw we are the elected
representative so we have the mandate
but whether we have the mandate use the
electoral roll for what is essentially
our job I'm not too sure paying citizens
to attend as a parish councilor I can
tell you that our parish council would
not be happy to hear that we had paid
for people to ascend to attend a
citizen's panel when it's our job anyhow
and to come back and counsel and mcgraw
touched on it the the task force we have
yet to put together and finalize the
terms of reference and they are keen
they really are key and I've already
made it known to my opposite number in
mid Suffolk that yes we want somebody
from right across the council to be part
of that task force but in order to
channel and focus the purpose of that
task force the terms of reference have
got to be pretty tight
yeah I'd just like to clarify that
tonight cancel a commenting and and can
commit to pledge to this emotion but
actually it's a cabinet function so it
will be for cabinet to decide the terms
of reference for the task force if you
were to agree it thank you
I think I agree with everyone roundish
tables been duly elected but we have
been elected to do what the public want
so that's how I feel about it thank you
any more comments are we ready to go to
a vote on the amendment right I think
we're ready to go to a vote on the
amendment now can we have those in favor
of the amendment please for for the
amendment can we now have eight against
the amendment please
the amendment is lost
so now we'll return to this of okay
sorry
abstentions any abstentions no there are
no abstentions
so now we'll return to the substantive
motion please um
councilman Yvonne to say anything
further about your substances motion you
madam chairman I've laid the motion in
front of Council and I'd be grateful if
we could now move to a vote to accept
I think councillor Davis wants to say
something but shortly we will think here
cuts the definite Davis yeah thank you
honey it's important that we do have a
little debate before we go straight to
the vote and there's a question actually
in the motion this is Babe Ruth Suffolk
are we capable are we able to make a
decision on bid suffix behalf we are two
separate sovereign councils and I
appreciated it is go to cabinet as well
that's my first point the second point
is I'm fully supportive of the motion I
think is important that we do act and
the terms emergency or whatever else
whatever
we definitely have a climate issue
worldwide not just in this country so
it's important that we as a council play
our part in doing whatever we can to to
help in that I'm a big believer in that
and I thought councillor God's
pre-meeting prayer was very very good
and very 6in and very relevant to this
because we are caretakers of this of
this planet and it's important that we
act to preserve it not just for
ourselves but for future generations as
well I'm a big believer in harness and
the beauty and the power that we have
and that's why one of the things I'd
like us to start doing everyone agrees
with me is to start using or exploring
the option of hydropower tidal power
call it what you want but to use the
natural resources that the earth has
given us in terms of the power from the
North Sea for us but worldwide as well
so I fully endorse and I will be voting
in favor of this same motion and chair
just to clarify of course as a sovereign
council you can only vote for matters
that we reflect or are in labor but of
course it's subjective because this
motion is going to meet Suffolk on
Thursday evenings as well thank you
any other comments councillor Lindsay
yes thank you
obviously I support this motion despite
the fact the amendment though I still
think it would be churlish to reject
this just because my amendment fellow
Barr amendment Phil it's massively
important I just wanted to say that I I
really think we do have to be aware of
what this does mean what we're
committing to because it means every
single I feel every single policy of a
council that we decide on whether the
cabinet or the full council has to be
scrutinized to see whether it moves
towards the goal of reducing carbon or
actually increases carbon and some of
the policies that we already have in
place and we had a discussion earlier at
the leaders meeting with councillor Ward
about this proposing our you know we're
in support of a subway bypass deal we're
supporting apes which northern bypass we
really do have to look at the research
on that and get a clearer view because
the evidence is that if you keep
building roads you're encouraging more
people onto the roads more transport and
it's not good enough to say that
electric cars will that's okay in a few
years time it will be electric
so there's no emissions there's an
article here from new scientists just in
March headline electric cars won't
shrink emissions enough we must cut
travel to and they quote Kevin Anderson
the Tindall Center for climate change
research one of the leading bodies on
climate change he says that it's not
enough we won't if we try and electrify
the current fleet decarbonize the
current car fleet it's not going to be
fast enough to meet the goals of zero
carbon by 2030 we must reduce the demand
for transport as well that means not
building more road space but actually
allowing more space in places like
Sudbury for public transport for buses
for cyclists
Walker's not having perhaps so many car
parts I think that's that's all I've got
to say on thank you Thank You counsel
cuts the beer thank you madam chairman
point of clarity to counselor Lindsay
you just said that we support the
Sudbury bypass which I do wasn't aware
you did will you clarify that and the
northern bypass districts which again I
support do you you're saying you did can
you please clarify whether you are
supporting the sub bypass and that it's
which northern bypass which is what
you've just referred that you were you
said we yes I'm sorry you misunderstood
by way I'm referring to the vision for
Sudbury which is it's produced I presume
by a council body so by we are referring
to baby council as a whole body me
personally I completely don't support
assembly by person nor do I support yes
can't some elf easy thank you madam
chairman I thoroughly commend councillor
Lindsey's sentiment but I don't think it
is within the councils remit to demand
that every business in this country
changes its business model that will
take time because it's only by changing
the business model that you're going to
get true effective absolute change
because most businesses rely on you
buying a new TV every three years a new
fridge every four or five a new washing
machine every five so do we change those
business models how do we influence that
we can't influence that so the motion
here is asking you to acknowledge that
we have an issue and to accept it
thank you madam chair
any further comment can't stomach roar
just to say I think we're already
pre-empting the work of the task force
perhaps we should vote can't smell feces
is there anything finally you'd like to
say so I think we're ready now to move
the motion oh thank you madam chairman
thank you so we're now fighting on
really pledging that the cabinet can go
on to to look into this so can we have a
vote for those in favor of the motion
please
I think that's an unanimous that's
unanimous
thank you so now we're going up on to
item 10 BC 1914 capital investment fund
company Cisco Capital Limited business
plating and performance report 2018-19
before we commence can I ask members to
ensure that they refrain from asking any
questions that relate to any information
that is in the exempt papers until the
meeting moves into the closed session it
is also my intention to move the
recommendation and vote on them in an
open session therefore there may be a
need to move from open to closed session
and then back again thank you I would
like to invite council Buzzbee vice
chair BDC Suffolk Holdings Limited to
introduce paper BC 1914 and to move the
recommendation 3.1 in the report
councillor Busby
this report sets out Pacifico capital
amenities trading activity in 2018-19
it reports performance against key
performance indicators that were set in
the previous years business plan the
report confirms that the first tranche
of investment was completed in March
2019 creating the portfolio which
delivers a net initial yield of 5.75%
appended to the reports in confidential
appendix a's the draft business plan for
2019-20
the business plan has been prepared by
the board of Cisco in consultation with
its fund managers Jones Lang LaSalle it
has been approved by the council holding
companies and endorsed by the joint
overview and scrutiny committee the
business plan forms the important part
of the government's governance of the
company I would therefore like to
propose that the recommendations set out
in section 3 of this report are approved
thank you Thank You Elsa Busby can I
have a seconder please Thank You
councillor hold right questions and
debate
most it is not really so much of a
question is just clarification I
actually asked the question before the
meeting started now I'd be surprised if
I was the only person who misunderstood
what it said on page 32 10.5 and that
paragraph it talks about the total
annual rent at 3 million 119 thousand
558 against the previously anticipated
rental income 2.8 million this includes
income from the first asset acquisition
at the second phase of investment and
then it says excluding this the income
sorry including this the income the
first phase of investment generates is
two point nine eight that doesn't
actually read particularly well so did
seek a bit of clarification and the
important thing is that that last
sentence starts with this which refers
to the three million 119 thousand not to
the 2.8 did everybody understand that
before I explained it so it's just to
clarify there Thank You councillor
a--they did you want to comment on that
at all councillor buzz feel you're happy
with that explanation any further
questions or statements or queries do we
need to go into clique do we need to go
into closed session or
can swim across madam chair if we
completed our coverage of the initial
part therefore I propose we move to part
two and then we can discuss the whole
board and the business plan okay just
domain went well good question yeah just
before we before we do do that madam
chair I wouldn't mind some clarification
if if possible even through the report
I'm struggling to see what it is within
the confidential paper that is
confidential if I'm being honest I'm
shocking to see if there's any
information here that wouldn't
ordinarily be gained from a view of
Companies House website so could we have
some clarification on why we should be
excluding the public from this session
Emily could you answer that please
hello and the the reason the business
plan is on the closed agenda is because
it does detail the operation of the
business Pacifico so I think it would be
unusual for a business plan to be in in
full and public detail in any other
situation but specifically I think the
confidentiality relates to details
regarding the tenant so any lease
expires that may come up we wouldn't
want that information to be public
information because it may lead to those
that tenants face being targeted when
the X bar is come up so it's more about
protecting and Pacifica Pacifico
business and and that lease data
I'm happy for discussion in relation to
the business plan to be on the open
agenda as long as it doesn't deal with
any of those tenants specific items so
yes
question on that which is if it's about
identifying the tenant in the open paper
we've got a picture of the premises and
it's got the occupiers name written on
it
it's not really about the name it's more
about the key dates so that's probably
more more of a commercial issue so if a
tenant is in a building then it's going
to advertise the fact that that tenants
in the building but what wouldn't be
advertised would be the terms of the
lease so that tenant occupies that
building so that's there's sort of more
confidential element rather than the
fact that that tenant exists and
occupies the space Council Lindsay
okay can I propose them that we do that
follow the offices suggestion that we as
long as we don't refer to the details of
that when the lease expires and the
weighted average these time that we have
having public because I do think that
the public kind of just I don't think
anything wrong with what we're deciding
and I think I think it's good to the
public should know what we check just to
clarify that is absolutely fine if we
stay in the open session we just just
the warning that if you do stray into
that we will need to go into closed at
that point right would you like to
continues anyone else for the question
councillor Davis yeah just put for my
own clarification so that we said we're
now in a public session but but the
session that the section regarding the
tenants information will be redacted
from the papers
chair threw you the papers will not be
in the public domain you're just going
to be talking around everything else
apart from those tenants details so they
will not go into the public domain that
the actual public interest test has been
undertaken and it has been decided that
if the interesting keeping them
confidential is above the public
interest in publishing and so we will
keep them and unpublished so does anyone
have any questions or much as they want
to discuss we're still in open session
council ward
I don't really want to ask any questions
I just want to stay fit from my own
personal view is that I know we've had a
lot of criticism in public and press and
mostly a fairly ill-founded that we're
concentrating on retail property but
it's quite clear from from what we're
what we've got here in these reports is
that that retail percentage has never
been as high as people would imagine it
was and indeed we are looking to
rebalance as as we invest further funds
and focus more on office accommodation
and industrial units so that we already
have a reasonably balanced portfolio and
that'll only get better as time goes by
and this report gives us the confidence
so that that's going to happen so from
my point of view is it's got everything
in that I'd like to see for for the
strategy for the future Council McCraw
ma'am chair I just occurs to me normally
this sort of thing comes out in the
course of the meeting but we are
broadcasting this on YouTube and the
members of the public and have asked
questions about it the press as has been
pointed out by counsel award have been
following this I wonder if it would be
helpful if a brief summary of the
highlights of the performance and the
highlights of the key performance
indicators for the business plan could
be introduced for the benefit of members
and for the benefit of the public
we have Managing Director of Cisco here
with us who probably knows as much about
it as any else / another person in the
room and I think it would be useful to
have that information in the public
domain and obviously with it being Emily
she'll know exactly what she can say
that should be in the public domain
because I think those pointers need to
be made public I would wonder if the way
that could be done
our chief executives wants to comment on
this just thought might be useful to
clarify for anyone who might be on there
any sense of confusion the pink papers
as so called are the confidential
elements and the majority pages 25
through to pages 42 are in the public
domain and they do cover some or without
reviewing the mode not so they will
cover necessarily all off but they send
the covers certainly most of those
questions that I think you've just
raised so a lot of the content that
you're asking to be in the public domain
is in the public domain and if there are
any other components that members feel
that they would like to see in the
public domain and subject to the advice
in terms of confidentiality they can be
put in the bug domain then of course we
wouldn't be able to do so I just want to
reassure members that all that stuff on
the white papers easy in the public
domain already including performance
data including yield data including
details of what properties we own
through Cisco and so on and so forth my
point was though could it be here stated
for the record and for broadcast as a
matter of it in four
the public by Emily that's possible that
just seems to me a reasonable way to
explain ourselves Emily hello yes I'm
I'm happy to summarize and so the the
the paper that is on the open agenda
does set out difficult performance
against its key performance indicators
and so the first key performance
indicator was the yield the target was
the six percent yield and the net
equivalent the sorry the net initial
yield that the portfolio has achieved is
five point seven five percent with an
equivalent yield of just shy of six
percent so in effect that target has
broadly been met and there has been
discussion about that yield and I think
one of the the challenges and important
aspects of creating a property portfolio
is to ensure that we get the right
portfolio so potentially we could have
achieved that six percent net initial
yield but that would have been meant
that we had a riskier portfolio overall
and the second key performance indicator
was in relation to completing the
acquisition phase the target was to
complete that in January there is
actually completed in March and so again
I think it's a similar situation I think
we have met that key performance
indicator within a reasonable tolerance
and it again
it was better to perhaps be a little
couple of months behind that and buy the
right assets rather than buying assets
just to meet that deadline so I think we
have a more secure portfolio and the
third KPI within the last year's
business plan was in relation to the
interest rates being charged between the
council and the trading company and
actually looked at a target dataset
the 19 so we've not actually met that
date yet however we are now also moving
into a second phase of investment and so
the suggestion is that it's not
appropriate to be meeting that key
performance indicator at this point in
time that we need to complete the second
phase of acquisitions so that's the
performance indicators the rest of the
report really out like some outlines
some of the key details about some of
the additional properties that have been
acquired and there is a lot of the
detail from the business plan actually
in that paper to ensure that the public
has as much access to data as as is
possible without getting into a
confidential territory and the other
aspect of the report really is just to
confirm that this is a an income fund so
the purpose of civico is to generate
income for the councils and that with
the first phase of investment now
completed just generating an income
approximately 1.4 million across the two
authorities so that's obviously a very
positive aspect does also highlight
within the public paper that cisco has
made a loss financial loss and the
reasons for the financial loss are
because of the cost of acquiring the
properties so stamp duty fees that the
set up cost effectively and also a small
fluctuation in property values which are
largely related to the retail assets
within the portfolio but again the paper
goes on earth is it that that is a sort
of reads more tolerance for three
valuations and sort of thing that we
should have expect on an annual basis to
see fluctuations in value either upwards
or downwards depending on
the market does that provide enough of
her summary got some across thank you
very much Emily um a couple of points I
just like to bring out when when you say
that the portfolio value has been
reduced but the value of the portfolio
as I understand it is not a primary
concern tsypko repay the council is this
correct at a fixed rate and the purpose
of Cisco's investments please correct me
if I'm wrong is to provide an income
okay when we when we examine properties
how many properties do we examine and
and what proportion do we end up
actually purchasing what's the
proportion the exact sorry the exact
figures are in the report but I can't
remember them off the top my head
although councillor Busby can and but we
do look at a significantly larger number
of properties and ones that we actually
acquire so over the last 12 months we
acquired six properties we've probably
looked at 70 or 80 properties and
discounted most of those and made offers
on I think possibly 10 or 12 so there is
quite a large sifting process that goes
through and our fund managers and
acquisition agents Jones Lang LaSalle
and also pre sift so before we get the
sort of 70 or 80 properties that come
through to us Jones Lang LaSalle are
also sifting through potentially
hundreds of properties and to see
whether they meet our criteria before we
even look at them so it's very kind of
detailed sifting process duties is
undertaken and certainly not one that's
that's unlikely
Castle Busby did you have something to
add look at page 31 10.4 is the I think
is the paragraph that gives you the
information that says we could consider
the assets of 77 assets we rejected 64
submitted offers on 13 and acquired six
I mean I think that
probably gives you all the information
you need to know and I guess the reason
for not hitting the kpi's was that we
were more interested in perhaps
insecurity than making a quick buck and
I hope that will continue we want to
make this as secure as possible for the
council and it means that we miss out on
a few properties then that's too bad if
we only get six point five point eight
percent yield instead of six percent
that's still a good return the most
important thing on here is the security
of the of the assets that we acquire
Thank You counsel Lynsey thank you
yet the the it strikes me that we
haven't got any information on the
average cost of borrowing we've got a
KPI for the yield but if if we happen to
borrow them which is 5.75 now if we
happen to borrow in the future we might
have to borrow it more than that this is
a brexit disaster bond market falls
through the floor interest rates or
suddenly we might not be able to borrow
so I wonder why there's no KPI for the
differential between cuz that's surely
what we need to be aiming at is getting
a higher return and so the table setter
at 10.1 set out the council's and
position and effectively what you've got
there is you've got the income that's
being received from Cisco and the cost
of borrowing so it then shows the net
figure so then that's the 1.4 million
that we've talked about that's the net
figure so that's the net income to the
council's after their borrowing costs
does that help put that question
and well it was really not really
because that gives an absolute amount
but I'm talking about going forwards
surely we need to have a mind to when we
setting goals for the board to invest
you need to have a mind to what what we
can borrow at as well as what the return
might be anted wise so in part that's
what the Ness initial yield and sets out
so we have a target for the yield so the
council's borrowing rates are
significantly below that so council
borrowing rates are more likely to be in
the order of two percent and as opposed
to add net initial yield at a sort of
target at five and three quarters so
there is already a gap there and the net
initial yield is reviewed on an annual
basis our target or our KPI and so we
can obviously continue to review that
and it will need to reflect interest
rates and there is normally a
relationship between those two in any
event so we would continue to review
that but but at this point in time we
believe that the sort of five and three
quarter percent target yield is
appropriate and reflects thee and the
sort of current borrowing rates that or
interest rates that were exposed to cuts
a Hardacre
we have crystal I know something in the
appendix on page 48 of the appendix in
the UK investment market is within the
retail sector standard shops are
expected to deliver their strongest
Eterna when X 5 years averaging four
point four percent per annum but the
evidence of my eye as ears tells me that
shops and high streets are closing down
record rate so there's two things in my
mind do it quite good to give us a quick
curious where that come from
[Music]
and so I just like to pass that question
on to Neville prick chard so Neville is
and a director at Jones Lang LaSalle and
wrote that commentary within the
business plan so it's probably best
place to answer that query good evening
ladies gentlemen as far as the various
sectors are concerned and retail has had
a torrid time recently and looking from
the high streets as you rightly say it's
tough that we all know that the sense
going forward is that it has hit a very
low point it is not going to bounce back
very swiftly but as far as the rents are
concerned and rents have dropped
significantly from where they were in
many cases a lot of occupiers are still
paying the rent switch or set time ago
because contractually their dues do that
Don knew lettings the rents have come
down considerably and they are starting
to get to a level where they are
starting to show a little bit of growth
coming forward of the very very low
basis now it's going to take time to
come through we do think it's going to
be a matter of no five years or so
before we see a lot of uptick from there
and in the meantime as we've projected
we think that the industrial sector in
particular and so the alternative
sectors are going to be the best
performers over the next few years
nothing lasts forever one of the reasons
for getting aged and spread across the
portfolio to the different sectors you
that when one element is down another
element starts to come back and vice
versa and so like any set of investments
it's good to spread the risk between a
variety of different sectors what we
tried to ensure is that in each sector
we selected assets which do offer a good
long term income stream to a strong
tenant as far as possible
in locations which are sound and which
offer good potential going forwards I
think it's right to say that if you look
at some of the smaller towns and some of
the weaker ends of the pitch then they
could never come back they could be down
for a long time in the stronger
locations and the better towns then we
feel that there are some positives to
come through but it will be a few years
probably get there Thank You councillor
Ward it just just quick 1 to 2 al a
castle of Lindsey's fears about interest
rates and I was at the LJ conference a
couple of weeks ago and we had a
presentation from Mark Carney and it's
his view that in the major economies in
the world their interest rates are on a
downward trend at the moment so but we
have a while before we need to worry too
much about our borrowing rate any
further comments or questions before we
go to the vote we're still in the open
session did anyone want to go to the
closed session for anything further
otherwise I think well I think we're
ready to go to the vote the
recommendations are on page 25 there are
two recommendations and we'll take them
both together so all those in favor of
the recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 could
you those in favor please
point of Orden and Jeff and we had a
proposal and seconder we have my
apologies back up again then so this is
in favor of point three point one and
two thank you those against no carried
thank you so I think we've now come to
the end of agenda today I just like to
remind you that the date of the next
meeting is Tuesday 24 September with a
different time as I mentioned earlier 6
p.m. for the next meeting in September
so I now close the meeting thank you
very much